in early may gas prices which were
already rising due to lifted pandemic
restrictions
shot up and it had a lot to do with this
the biggest fuel pipeline system in the
united states forced to shut down
a suspected cyber attack is cyber
extortion attempt
on may 7 the nation's largest fuel
pipeline colonial
shut down for six days in response to a
ransomware attack that targeted the
company's networks
we have efforts underway with the fbi
and doj
department of justice to disrupt and
and prosecute ransomware criminals the
attack drove panic consumers to
stockpile fuel
in states heavily impacted by the
shutdown like north and south carolina
georgia and virginia
this caused long lines and shortages at
gas stations
the colonial pipeline cyber attack was
the latest high profile event to expose
a threat
to aging vulnerable energy
infrastructure in the u.s
so just how vulnerable are we to future
attacks
our energy infrastructure is under
attack and has been
under attack for at least two decades
now so both from a physical perspective
but also digital teresa payton is a
cyber security expert
and former white house chief information
officer under the bush administration
she says that the energy infrastructure
that fuels the us
is highly vulnerable to attacks like
this the country
has around two and a half million miles
of fuel pipelines
and colonial is a major part of this
network stretching from texas to new
jersey
each pipeline includes hundreds of
thousands of devices
sensors for readings valves that help
control flow and pressure
and leak detection systems security
experts say that all are at risk in an
attack
while most equipment isn't directly
connected to the internet
the concern is that hackers can
penetrate digitized tools
or computer networks working their way
into broader systems
cyber criminals will often infiltrate
systems through remote platform hacking
email phishing schemes or through
compromised employee credentials
once they penetrate it they study the
traffic of the accounts on the network
and they learn how to hide in plain
sight i liken it to
somebody who may be using rush hour
traffic
to basically hide their car among
hundreds and thousands of vehicles in
rush hour
it's hard to pick out the bad actor when
they're just kind of going with the flow
of the traffic
once hackers are inside they can use
malicious code to lock up systems
or steal sensitive information to extort
their victims
and these type of cyber attacks can have
far-reaching effects
you have seen after hurricanes where
that has taken part of our
energy infrastructure offline and sort
of what the downstream impacts are for
weeks
and months afterwards and so a cyber
incident can have the same or even more
devastating
effects on our energy ecosystem
so why are the nation's most critical
energy systems
so exposed to cyber crime payton says
that as older systems are updated and
digitized
they've become more complex which
hackers have taken advantage of
we're integrating 5g technology smart
grid technology
sort of alternative and renewable
sustainable energy sources
and each time you layer on these new
technologies
these new technologies are unproven as
far as
how they will stand up to a cyber attack
in the u.s there's also high demand for
energy to always be on and working
which makes it difficult for systems to
be updated
replacing outdated systems is also
expensive and time-consuming
but it's not just aging infrastructure
and a lack of resources
that expose energy systems to cyber
attacks
experts say that hackers are becoming
increasingly organized
within the ransomware industry they'll
use a combination of burner phones
dark web forums using handles in reddit
using code words
when they're trying to recruit people
and with
more and more silicon valley companies
rolling out
encryption built in as part of messaging
platforms
it makes it simpler for them to just use
commercially available
tools after a successful attack
cyber criminals can demand payment in
cryptocurrency
which limits the ability of law
enforcement to track them
there's also been a growth in insurance
policies that cover ransomware payments
which could help boost the illegal
industry experts say attacks like the
one on the colonial pipeline
are becoming more frequent in 2020
energy companies suffered the third
largest number of cyber attacks of any
industry
up from ninth place the previous year
but there's only a patchwork of cyber
security regulations for energy
companies
and the pipeline sector is largely
unregulated
on may 10th president biden said that
his administration was pursuing a global
effort
to protect american companies and
infrastructure from ransomware attacks
it begins with a 100-day sprint to
improve cyber security
in the electric sector and we'll follow
that with similar initiatives in natural
gas pipelines water and other sectors
in addition to companies stepping up we
need to invest
to safeguard our critical infrastructure
the colonial pipeline started to resume
operations on may 12th
but experts say the cyber attack should
still serve as a wake-up call for the
energy industry